ukraine's president has urged the
world's leading natural gas producer
qatar to increase its output vladimir
zelinski said that would stop russia
using energy as a weapon he was speaking
at the doha forum via video link from
ukraine the first such address to a gulf
nation since the war began
this is also a question of abandoning
the usage of russian oil and gas
responsible states like the state of
qatar are reliable and solid exporters
of energy resources and they can make
their contribution to the stabilization
in europe they can do much to restore
justice the future of europe rests with
your efforts it depends on your efforts
i ask you to increase the output of
energy to ensure that everyone in russia
understands that no country can use
energy as a weapon
let's go to jamal elshail who is live at
the forum here in doha jamal that was a
surprise address by the president of
ukraine what else did he have to say at
the doha forum
well it was yesterday was not announced
to be part of the program whether that's
because of
you know maybe attempts by the
organizers to try and bring in also the
russian side or whether it was a
last-minute one but nonetheless zelensky
used the opportunity to address uh
over a dozen world leaders participating
or at least foreign ministers
participating at this year's forum to
further press them to take stronger
action in putting an end to russia's
invasion of ukraine and the war on his
country he pleaded with the
international community
to take further steps in isolating
moscow and putting pressure on it one of
them as we heard there was to boycott
the import of
russian oil and gas and call to
gas-rich nations like qatar to step in
and fill the void and even if qatar
would want to do something like this and
as lucrative as it would be would be
almost impossible to fill up
30 percent of
europe's energy needs which are
currently being supplied by russia that
being said qatar wants to play a role
mediating and obviously with this
leverage there that could be an avenue
for it to use
jamal stay with us for just a moment
because we are going to play out a sound
bite from kasamir sheikh tamim bin hamad
al-thani who opened the event at the
doha forum
i emphasized the firm position of the
state of qatar on the renunciation of
violence intimidating civilians and
assaulting state sovereignty and all
other acts that may constitute a
violation of human values and
international laws we stand in
solidarity with the millions of innocent
people and refugees who've been
victimized by this unjust war and
geopolitical calculations
jamal uh qatasamia there uh talking
about ukraine even before we saw uh
president zielenski there clearly the
conflict is weighing on the qataris
it is a a obviously it's it's it's a
it's a key agenda or item agenda for
everybody in the international community
and every uh country and obviously as
far as qatar is concerned as we were
saying there it does have a track record
of uh being an interlocutor in being a
mediator in conflict
conflicts and
would like to play a bigger role in
finding a peaceful solution or a
diplomatic solution to the war there and
that is something that the katari amir
spoke of but obviously his address
wasn't limited to the war in ukraine he
did speak about
the millions of refugees that have been
pushed away from their homes
around the world particularly when we
look at this region when we look at for
example the millions of syrian refugees
made homeless by russia when we look at
the millions of palestinian refugees who
have been refugees for decades because
of the occupation of their land when you
look at afghanistan yemen and so forth
so
did speak about this he did speak about
the need for
pluralism for diplomacy for negotiations
and discussions to take place not purely
to tick a box that they are taking place
but to find a solution herein is where
we find the role of something like the
forum as far as the qataris are
concerned they say that this is a
platform to try and find a
viable and realistic
common ground between different actors
globally regionally and within their
respective countries to have a meeting
ground where they can discuss ways to
resolve conflicts but also to overcome
challenges because it's not just about
conflicts there are global challenges
whether it's economic and obviously
inflation and other
issues that are going around the world
or even the environment and other things
like that all of that will be discussed
in expert sessions over the coming 48
hours
okay thank you for that jamal al-shal
speaking to us there live from the doha
forum